in New Orleans what are you expecting to
see out of johnan tonight Kenny energy
you know you're going to miss shots
you're going to make shots you're gonna
be um you know but the one thing that
also was missing with Dylan Brooks is
enthusiasm and effort you know and so
that's what he could bring to the team
bringing enthusiasm because I I always
say professional athletes are are this
if you don't see the light at the end of
the Tuttle guys sometimes shut down
great players don't but you know good
players can and so him can start showing
light at the end of the tunnel and turn
on the light to some of those guys who
probably haven't had their light on uh
in about maybe 10 12 games the way if
you look at their record you know and
the way they're playing at 6 and 19 so
um he's going to turn the light on the
lights back
on I'm I'm looking forward to seeing
what type of shape he's in we we know
that there's no way to replicate a game
you can play with your boys you can go
to LA play Fitness 24 Hour Fitness
there's no way and he has been
practicing with the team okay so that's
good to know he's been practicing with
the
team I'm anxious to see what type of
shape is he in and and and his energy
level if I'm John Morant I know
everything's my fault I'm taking on that
villain role and I'm going for the
eighth spot right now we're not a good
team we have to make up eight games is
John Morant good enough to make up eight
games the Poss to get in that eth spot I
say is so tonight is the night we start
chck they only got to get 10
that's right that's right so what's done
is done he made mistakes he's paid for
his mistakes if I'm John Mor I'm
focusing on getting my team back in
track CU last two years they were very
exciting so now except that villain role
everybody's counting you out this is
when you got to step your G mod so I'm
I'm I'm anxious to see which players is
was uh coming out to play tonight they
have had losing streaks of six and five
already this season previous three years
one losing streak of at least five games
your expectations I'm excited to see him
he obviously screwed up
twice uh but see the problem with
screwing up it ain't always about you
he's hand he's handcuffed his team you
know that that's the thing when you same
thing with Draymond when you do stuff
you penalize the team team didn't do
anything because of you doing something
stupid now they in a struggle be like
it's going to be hard for them to make
the playoffs but I hope he learned his
lesson I hope he got some good people
around on him um these guys are so young
Ernie they make so much money like you
have to surround yourself with good
people and it's not easy do you see him
in the do you see him at least in the
playin no you don't you don't see them
making up that ground with johnar back
well cuz they Warriors the only team
that can fall out of that is Houston
they're either going to be really
they're going to stay consistent or
they're going to maybe come back your
question yes Ernie he's good enough he's
good enough I think he's going to be
anxious I think he's ready to play I
think he's ready to make the world
forget about his mistakes cuz you know
two or three four or five games
everybody's back on that band like you
know we'll we'll always remember what he
did but come out and score 50 tonight
and 50 come out and score 50 tonight and
watch what everybody I I I I would like
to see him play more under control
because those guy's been there for 3
months he just can't come back and take
all the shots D listen they he been
there they' been go he been gone for
three months to they 6 and 19 come back
into what you do
man was 6 and 19 it like they played
well when he was going I'm just saying
he can't come back and take all the
shots take them all take them all matter
fact here take this too some tissue you
sound like you got
congestion you know who you sound like
non-co illness I don't question who you
sound like got to play you know who you
sound like Chuck who snotty
Pippen
hi there it is not even
Hipp